lieber Tim Bendzko wir haben eine Frage
an dich wir sind Y-TITTY von Youtube
machen Song Parodien und haben unter
anderem auch deinen Song parodiert wenn
du das noch nicht wusstest dann schau
ihn dir jetzt mal an und dann würde es
uns einfach brennend interessieren was
du davon hältst
ja hallo weiteti
Komma
diese Parodie habe ich gesehen die wurde
ja auch öfter angeklickt als das Video
Ursprung glaube ich ähm ich finde das
habt Ihr sehr schön gedreht also es ist
einfach
beschrieben habe und der Text ja
habt ihr auch ganz toll
aber ist aber das Video für dich beim
Text ein bisschen
Jogi würde sagen muss tiefer stehen
aber wie du das wirklich krass was sie
davon betrieben aber vor allem diese
tunnelszene da hat euch gezeigt ich
hatte da kein double ich hatte eins aber
es war sehr gut aus
super
finde ich auch nur halb so gut aussieht
wie die junge Frau mein Video viel Glück
bei der Suche